what's going on guys this is rob and
episode four of wanda vision was kind of
insane
and here's a funny thing it looks like
there wasn't a whole lot going on there
but there was a lot happening if you
knew what to look for but there are two
big questions that are still
plaguing me after episode number four
the first one is why is agnes there to
help and the second
how did wanda learn that she could do
all of this now to the first question
the reason we know agnes is there to
help is because we hear her say that in
the trailer now i'm taking this at face
value in the sense that she
is actually there to help as opposed to
the idea that she's saying she's there
to help but she's actually there to
cause problems i'm just gonna go ahead
and assume that's the case
the second thing is that with episode
number four this game is a time frame
and we previously didn't have one we
just kind of assumed that it took place
at some point after avengers in game but
we didn't know exactly when
what we're basically told here is that
the events of wand division seemingly
start within
three weeks of the end of end game and
the reason why is because after end game
ended everybody got blipped back to life
monica comes back to life and then three
weeks after she returns
she goes and she reports to sword now at
that point one division or the beginning
of wanda creating her reality had
already happened
exactly how long it had happened i think
it was only a few days and so the
results of this is that within about two
and a half weeks
everything with one division popped off
after the events of avengers in game
this raises some very important
questions with regards to how did wanda
learn she could do this kind of thing
because by the end of avengers in-game
all wanda was able to do was basically
use her telekinesis there was no
indication she could alter reality in
any form or fashion
if she could she would have and so the
question becomes how did wanda go from a
person who could use telekinesis at the
end of avengers in-game to two and a
half weeks later
being able to create her own little
pocket reality on the planet earth now i
think this comes in the form of an
answer that seems the most unlikely
place
i think she got her hands on the dark
hole now the question is what's the dark
hold okay the dark hold is an artifact
that's appeared in the marvel cinematic
universe and it's actually from marvel
comics now in marvel comics the dark
hold is a book that has
ties directly to the entity cathode this
super powerful evil demonic entity that
wants to possess one to maxim off right
the prophecy is that he will
and that when he does he'll basically
take over the world we saw him possess
her multiple times he never took over
the world so prophecy more or less seems
to be nonsense but the overall gist here
is that in the marvel cinematic universe
the difference between
the comic book version and the mcu
version is that in the marvel cinematic
universe the dark hold is basically a
byproduct of what's called the hell
dimension or the dark dimension now we
can explain the hell dimension or dark
dimension
whatever you want to call it we can
explain it more in depth in terms of his
comic book version
because it actually makes a lot more
sense when you break it down and you
learn the origins of like mephisto
and all those guys but for our purposes
here the dark dimension is a singular
dimension out there that is currently
ruled over by dormammu but we know he's
not the only occupant in the dark
dimension we know that from the runaways
which is a marvel studios television
show that gave us morgan le faye who
came from the dark dimension among other
people and so we know that those
individuals who wield the dark hold have
the ability to manipulate the magic of
the dark dimensions so my thought here
is that somehow
wanda managed to get her hands on the
book now the most likely explanation
is that following the events of avengers
end game dr strange
kind of took her under her wing or at
the very least she traveled with him
maybe back to the sanctum sanctorum and
she saw some of the stuff that was going
on there and then ultimately managed to
find the darkhold look maybe it spoke to
her because we know the darkhold will
draw the attention of people that it
feels like it can use to achieve its own
ends i.e whoever's controlling that book
which is effectively dormammu will use
those people to achieve his own goals ah
this is an interesting concept because
one of the things that you saw in
episode four
is that the entire force field that goes
around westview
is in the shape of a hexagon why does
that matter because in doctor strange
all the books
are confined in hexagon patterns when
they're held in the library it was one
of the things that has happened to some
lacrosse i was just watching doctor
strange looking for clues and i was like
wait a minute on top of that when you
have the forces of kaiselius and his
guys basically summoning the power of
dormammu they're standing in a hexagon
so the idea of the hexagon is a constant
theme throughout doctor strange is it
loosely affiliated
sure and i don't really know if it hits
anything in particular but assuming that
actually happened
and that wanda maximoff did come into
contact with the darkhold then it makes
perfect sense the dark hole is how she's
doing all this
because the dark hold is basically a
wishing book anybody who opens it up
will see blank pages until the book
starts talking to them and then they'll
actually see these different spells and
incantations written all throughout the
book which grants them anything from the
ability to make force fields to
being able to alter reality to
resurrecting the dead you can do all
kinds of stuff with it and there's no
reason to believe that if she got her
hands on the dark hole she wouldn't be
able to do all this now the question
becomes
if she did get her hands on the dark
hole what's the point
right why would her having the dark hole
or why would dormammu even want her in
the first place well this answer comes
by way of a couple different things
one of the big theories going on out
there is that because vision is back and
alive that wanda recreated the mind
stone and that's how vision comes into
existence that's not true we know that
through episode number four that wanda
lost her concentration momentarily when
she ejected
monica from the one division world and
when vision walked in that vision
looked the way he actually looks right
when he looks dead he's got that hole in
his head that's how he actually looks
the way that we see him where he looks
like he always did where he's
essentially normal that's how wanda
makes him look
using her powers but the other thing is
that the influence of the dark dimension
becomes more and more powerful over the
person who's wielding the dark hole to
the point that it actually starts to
corrupt that person to a degree that
becomes a prominent factor when you look
at wanda's reaction
after she ejects monica out of the one
division world she's almost confused and
a little bit scared of what she did it's
one of these things where you can kind
of go either way
we can look at it in the sense that
wanda is becoming afraid of her own
power or we can look at it as though
she's being overtaken by this power that
she has
essentially the dark hole but she's
basically justifying it by saying well
it's okay because i'm able to maintain
my own little world i can control all of
this and that's the the
statement that she gives to vision when
she says it's okay i have everything
under control she doesn't she doesn't
have everything under control she's
slowly succumbing to the influence and
the power
of the darkhold which in turn is being
influenced by dormammu now to answer
this question
why does it matter because one division
if you take a step back and you look at
it for what it is it's a prelude
right it's a prelude to doctor strange
too we've been told that by kevin feige
we've been told that by the people who
were creating it we've been told it's a
prelude story now if you're somebody
like me who's been reading comic books
for 25 years
you know what preludes are that if we
look at this for what it is then we can
say okay so wanna got her hands on the
dark hold the dark hole is basically
exerting its influence over her she's
able to use it for its own ends but she
doesn't really understand the gravity of
what she's doing the dark hole itself
was created or in some way
influenced by dormammu who wants the
scarlet witch and the reason why he
wants the scarlet witch is because the
scarlet witch is a means by which
dormammu can effectively
influence everything outside of the dark
dimension that's the main goal of him as
a villain we learned that in doctor
strange one that what dormammu wants to
do is essentially take all of his power
and influence in the dark dimension
and spread it throughout the multiverse
and effectively conquer everything now
why in turn would this be the motivation
of dormammu as it applies to the scarlet
witch
because dormammu is not just dormammu in
the marvel cinematic universe dormammu
is a combination of kathon
and mephisto from marvel comics all
neatly wrapped up into one individual
and i think that makes perfect sense
the idea of the devil walking around and
tricking people into giving up their
souls for some measure of temporary
power
seems far-fetched even for a comic book
movie but having one singular
nigh omnipotent and malevolent being out
there that just wants to make people
suffer in eternal darkness makes a lot
more sense i don't know makes more sense
to me
but that's my thought on all this right
because of what's going on at the end of
one division in effect the scarlet witch
is going to
basically become the vector by which
dormammu is able to leave the dark
dimension and travel throughout the rest
of the multiverse
wreaking all kinds of havoc this is
going to lead to doctor strange making
an appearance at the end of wanda vision
snatching her up and saying come on like
we got to go solve this because you're
part of the reason why and ultimately
the whole multiverse of madness story is
dormammu's influence
reaching throughout the multiverse and
him causing all kinds of different
problems they're just fighting a series
of small battles in order to win a
greater war we'll probably also end up
seeing a whole bunch of other characters
maybe mephisto does exist
we're gonna see nightmare people like
that so we know a lot of those entities
will actually exist out there or
they're simply going to manifest as
facsimiles of dormammu
nightmare is a representation of every
single person out there and the
nightmares they have which is a part of
dormammu who just kind of walks around
as a singular being i don't really know
but if you guys are interested in
learning more about
mephisto in marvel comics you guys can
of course click on the end screen that
has mephisto
explained in marvel if you guys are
interested in learning more about our
various theories and the knowledge that
we hold here at pop culture explained
about marvel comics then feel free to
check out our wand division theories and
easter eggs playlist
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end and i will
catch you all later
peace